[Music]
this is the future of spacesuits
everything about the new Boeing blue
suit is streamlined and modern from the
sporty new space boots designed with
Reebok to the soft zip on hoodie helmet
it's superlight just 20 pounds and
packed with 21st century tech the gloves
are built for touchscreens the shoulders
and knees are made for movement each
suit is custom fitted to an astronaut
but modern as it is its job is the same
as every spacesuit that's come before it
protect a human body as it Rockets away
from her first there were the mercury
suits Alan Shepard the first American in
space wore one and so did John Glenn in
the orbited earth BFGoodrich modified
Navy mark for high altitude pressure
suits for space travel the aluminized
nylon suits weighed 22 pounds and had as
many as 27 zippers to customize the fit
the coolest of all some of them had tiny
lights attached to the fingertips in
case the capsule illumination failed how
do you like that et
[Music]
for the Gemini missions astronauts wore
a new suit designed not just for takeoff
and reentry the aviary helmet has three
visors but four spacewalks as well I
feel bad for the Apollo missions
astronauts donned variations on the a7l
suit which was made for launch and for
walking and driving on the moon
the suits came with the famous fish bowl
in trivia killer helmets when the space
shuttle first lifted off in 1981
astronauts again were modified high
altitude pressure suits that suit was
soon replaced by the familiar orange
pumpkin suit these came with a parachute
a life raft survival gear and a
30-minute supply of oxygen now we have
the Boeing blue the suits still have to
undergo more testing before astronauts
board the Starliner capsule and blast
off atop an Atlas rocket to the
International Space Station
so get ready Major Tom zip your helmet
we're go for launch you were ready to
take America back in the face